les restes d'un soldat soviétique exhumé
et d'une fosse commune de la chaussée de
leningrad
je vous laisse juge ces images en direct
[Musique]
on
on vous a retrouvé vous nous avez vous
nous fait vivre cette commémoration en
direct un mot que représente le 9 mai
aux yeux des russes
on en reparle dans un instant on écoute
d'abord vladimir poutine et qui
s'adresse à la nation ses concitoyens de
la russie chers anciens combattants
chers amis de tout mon coeur je vous
adresse mes félicitations pour ce jour
de la victoire pour nous tous c'est une
fête la plus importante la plus chère
toujours nos commémorer cet anniversaire
avec toute notre pays tous ensemble l'
importance spirituelle de ce jour est
très grand et notre attitude envers
cette fête est sacrée c'est notre fierté
c'est l'histoire de notre pays
l'histoire de chaque famille une partie
de notre âme partagé par nos pères nos
grands-pères ressentons avec beaucoup
d'acuité l'importance de cette fête nous
donnerons la mémoire de ceux qui sont
partis
nous regardons les photos jaunies
nous souhaitons une bonne vie à tous
ceux qui vivent aujourd'hui notre
respectons la grande génération des
vainqueurs et qu'ils ont fait pour notre
patrie ce qui ne peut pas être mesurée
payer ils sont sauvés notre patrie et la
vie des générations à venir
ils ont défendu l'europe et ils on se
regardait la paix ils ont restauré les
villes et les villages
ils ont réalisé des grandes acquis nos
vous honorons l'exploit énorme du peuple
soviétique qui était composée de toutes
ethnies et de toutes nationalités coude
à coude
ils ont combattu le temps n'a pas effacé
leur dignité et leur force de l'âme qui
est fait d'acier
chers amis ici devant la muraille du
kremlin
c'est une place sacrée pour nous tous
devant cette flamme éternelle à la
mémoire de ceux qui ont perdu leur vie
ici nous rendons hommage au soldat
inconnu au héros qui sont restés dans
des tombes inconnu sous moscou smolensk
et stalingrad course que sébastopol
minsk et kiev riga berlin et vienne pour
mon paul queveau sur les rives de la
nive à du danube de la vistule des
millions de ceux qui sont pris et qui
n'ont pas vu ce jour de la victoire tant
rêver et ils ont pu l'espérance de
revenir chez eux ils ont combattu pour
cette victoire jusqu'à la dernière
goutte du sang ils ont perdu leur vie
pour que nous et les générations à venir
nos fils nos enfants nos filles ils
vivent en paix ils ont sauvegardé la
paix c'est l'exploit du soldat
soviétique
nous nous plions devant la mémoire de
ceux qui sont péri devant la mémoire des
fils des filles des pères des mères des
grands pères
des maris des femmes des frères des
soeurs des camarades du régiment des
proches de famille des amis respectant
une minute de silence
chers amis 75 ans sont passés après la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale la
grande guerre patriotique nous allons
commémorer cet anniversaire comme la
tradition le veut avec toute la dignité
devant notre fierté devant ceux qui sont
tombés et qui ont fait la grande
victoire
nous allons organiser le défilé
militaire sur la place rouge et la
marche du régiment immortel pour
témoigner de ce lien historique
ils ont combattu contre la mort pour la
vie et nous nous alignons sur leur
dignité
nous sommes réunis dans cet espoir dans
cet espoir dans ses aspirations
la responsabilité pour le présent et
pour l'avenir nos savons et nous avons
cette assurance que nous sommes un
vicieux invincible quand nous sommes
ensemble
bonne fête bonjour de la victoire 1 pour
[Musique]
et voilà vous venez d'entendre le
président russe vladimir poutine
s'adresser à la nation quelques minutes
plus tôt il a donc déposé cette gerbe de
fleurs près de la flamme à terre plein
près de la flamme éternelle sur la plage
vous la place rouge de moscou antoine
expliquez nous le symbole rappeler nos
symboles de cette flamme éternelle
cette flamme éternelle a été a été
inauguré en 1967 par léonid brejnev le
premier secrétaire du parti communiste
un an après l'inauguration du tombeau du
soldat inconnu tout comme à paris sous
l'arc de triomphe repose le corps d'un
soldat un soldat tombé en 1941 lors de
la bataille de moscou et dont le corps a
été exhumé d'une fosse commune sur la
route de leningrad un petit peu au nord
de la capitale russe mais je crois que
cette inscription ton nom est inconnu
tout un exploit est immortel vladimir
poutine et qui a eu ces mots à l'instant
il a rappelé l'importance spirituel de
ce jour de la victoire c'est notre
fierté c'est l'histoire de notre pays
vladimir poutine qui a rendu hommage au
soldat inconnu au héros qui sont morts
au cours
du conflit doit se dérouler maintenant à
un défilé aérien en toile oui tout à
fait cette année pas de défilé militaire
au sens classique du terme avec des
régiments des tentes des blindés ou
encore des véhicules porte missiles non
rien de tout ça juste la partie le volet
aérien de cette parade a été maintenue
donc d'ici quelques minutes vont
survoler au dessus de la place rouge au
dessus de moi des hélicoptères et des
avions de combat pour un total de 75
appareils pour marquer le coup pour
marquer le 75e anniversaire anniversaire
de la victoire soviétique sur
l'allemagne nazie
merci antoine et retour sur la place
rouge vous vivez en direct ces
commémorations du jour de la victoire
des festivités qui ont été revues à
minima en raison de la crise du
coronavirus évidemment le défilé
militaire annoncée grandiose cette année
aura lieu un peu plus tard on regarde
ces images ensemble
[Musique]
là
à
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
là
et voilà vous venez de voir
on dirait que ces images depuis la place
rouge de moscou on retrouve antoine
claireaux vous vous suivez avec nous ces
commémorations du jour de la victoire en
russie
on vient de voir à l'instant vladimir
poutine déposé des roses sur ce qu'on
imagine être des tombeaux de soldats
morts au combat expliquez-nous la
symbolique est ce que qu'est-ce qui a
qu'à qui rend hommage à l'instant un
vladimir poutine très précisément alors
dans son allocution il a rendu hommage à
tous les combattants tombés pour pour la
patrie mais là il s'agit en fait des
stèles qui correspondent aux villes qui
ont le statut de héros héros de du
soviétisme c'est à dire les villes qui
ont subi les pertes les plus lourdes qui
ont connu les combats les plus terribles
on peut penser à la ville de stalingrad
aujourd'hui volgograd ou encore à saint
pétersbourg leningrad avant qui a connu
un siège extrêmement extrêmement tenace
et extrêmement coûteux en vies humaines
donc c'est ceci à ceux ci qu'il rend
hommage en déposant ses fleurs devant
ces stèles merci beaucoup en toile et
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de nos
deux invités claude blanchemaison que
représente le 9 mai pour pour les russes
parce que on le rappelle quand même la
seconde guerre mondiale a fait près de
25 millions de morts en urss et un
environnement extrêmement lourd en plus
de la moitié des victimes
25 millions de morts dont près de la
moitié étaient des civils
d'ailleurs donc en effet en russie c'est
un souvenir très douloureux auquel
d'ailleurs s'est référé le président
coûter dans son allocution qu est une
allocution très sobre où il a beaucoup
parlé en effet de ceux qui sont morts
pendant cette guerre de leur famille il
a rappelé que le
défilé des immortels qui avait été
inauguré en 2015 aura lieu à la suite de
la la parade sur la place rouge qui n'a
été que reporté mais cet hommage aura
lieu alors je crois que dans la mémoire
de tous les russes en effet c'est à une
date très importante dans celle de
vladimir poutine aussi parce que
évidemment il est né en 1952 mais ses
parents son père et sa mère lui ont
raconté pendant toute sa jeunesse
comment il avait failli mourir à
plusieurs reprises pendant ce siège de
leningrad qui a duré de près de 900
jours
son père a failli mourir à plusieurs
reprises il combattait derrière les
lignes nazis en faisant des attentats
est en effet à plusieurs reprises il a
été laissé pour mort sa mère aussi a été
laissée pour morte et elle était sauvé
un petit peu par par miracle donc il en
a un souvenir très très très précis
puisque pendant toute sa jeunesse il a
entendu parler de cette ceci s saint pé
de saint pétersbourg de leningrad à
l'époque qui a été véritablement une
horreur donc je crois que ceci marque en
effet la victoire sur le nazisme et on
voit bien que les russes insistent
là-dessus par une victoire sur
l'allemagne victoire sur le nazisme et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est fait par
ailleurs hier à paris wallon aujourd'hui
le 9 mai devenu un rendez-vous
patriotique c'est une dette très
importante pour pour les russes oui
c'est une date très importante c'est
vraiment la plus importante parce que la
russie a dans le fond a failli périr
devant l'invasion nazie et de la liqueur
poutine à déposé
en effet une fleur sur les stèles qui
représentent chacune une grande bataille
avec le nom de la ville où s'est
déroulée cette bataille
et effectivement toute la russie se sent
concerné par cette part cette part se
souvenir
françois chavancy vous vous êtes avec
nous vous aussi rappelé le rôle joué par
l'union soviétique dans la bataille
contre le nazisme justement dans la
guerre et dans la victoire
je crois qu'il ya deux phases la
première fois n'oublions pas 1941 1941
l'armée rouge et désorganisés des
accords ont été passés avec l'allemagne
nazie et staline croit sans doute à la
paix avec le dictateur de l'ouest
l'armée rouge je subis des énormes le
vin à partir du 22 juin 1941
et puis le tour on en saura vers 1943 de
temps on parle beaucoup de batailles de
course bataille de chars énorme avec
normand de matériel et de part et
d'autre
et finalement c'est commence à être
leurs tourments de situation d'abord
remarquons quand même que je dirais
l'esprit russe peut-être plus que
l'esprit soviétique
même si le soviétisme était derrière a
été comme de résister à l'envahisseur et
je crois que c'est ça le grand symbole
de cette guerre dite patriotique c'est
que les peuples de l'ex union soviétique
et la russie en particulier se sont
rebellés face à cette invasion ont
résisté ont fait preuve tout de ce conte
dire aux gens d'une grande résilience
même s'il y avait un état derrière qui
ne permettait pas qu'on puisse dévié du
choix de la guerre mais surtout cette
grande résilience du peuple qui a
résisté comme l'a très bien souligné
notre interlocuteur
le peuple et l'armée étaient unis face à
l'invasion et n'oublions pas ce qui a
été rappelé d'ailleurs lors des
différents discours le massacre des
populations civiles
quand même n'oublions pas que les nazis
ont massacré les civils les militaires
au mépris de toutes les règles et même
au nom du droit de la guerre
le droit de la guerre on respecte des
prisonniers l'allemagne nazie a massacré
tout le monde prenant justement le
peuple russe pour un peuple du peuple
slave d'ailleurs en général comme un
peuple entre guillemets d'esclaves
or que ce qu'ont montré les russes c'est
cette formidable aptitude à résister à
se battre et finalement à vaincre et
retourne tout c'est sûr
la place rouge de moscou avec ce défilé
aérien qui commence à l'instant puisque
seuls ont été maintenus ces vols
d'avions militaires ils veulent donc
aussi la chômage de 75 à paris
hélicoptères et avions des forces 0
spatiale russe ont décollé des huit
aérodromes et ont formé des patrouilles
dans une zone qui est située aux
environs de moscou pour passer ensuite
au dessus de la place rouge
les appareils volent altitude de 150 à
400 mètres la vitesse de 200 et à 500 m
le défilé ouvert par l'hélicoptère de
transport qui a la plus grande charge
utile au monde
le mil mi 26 qui est accompagné de
quatre hélicoptères multi rôles mil mi 8
ce groupe est conduit par le
lieutenant-colonel saga poliakova vous
voyez maintenant une formation de cinq
hélicoptères de transport de combat mil
mi 35m sous les ordres du lieutenant
colonel canadien coc les accords va
[Musique]
après les mi-35 reviennent cinq
hélicoptères de combat kamov ka 52
alligator ce sont les hélicoptères
d'appui feu des troupes au sol
cette formation est conduite par le
colonel vassili klitschko
[Musique]
voici une patrouille d'acrobaties
aériennes berkut est déloyal sur cinq
hélicoptères d'attaqué mil mi 28n qui
sont baptisés chasseur de nuit
la patrouille est placée sous les ordres
du colonel andré pauvres ils sont suivis
par un avion de détection de
commandement aéroporté à 50 ou qui est
capable de suivre en même temps plus de
50 cibles aériennes
cet avion est piloté par le colonel
jesse la flèche tienko vient ensuite une
formation de trois avions de transport
militaire long-courrier iliouchine il 76
mde qui sont modernisés et qui sont
capables d'acheminer un fret de plus de
40 tonnes dans des régions les plus
éloignées dans le ciel de moscou vous
voyez passer trois bombardiers
stratégiques louera à turbopropulseurs
topo lève tout 95 m s c'est une des
composante aérienne des forces de
dissuasion nucléaire cette formation est
placée sous les ordres du lieutenant
colonel sergueï iline l'aviation
stratégique et représente également par
une patrouille qui est composé d'un bon
parti et au collège tout 160 à géométrie
variable et de quatre bombardiers
supersoniques à long rayon d'action topo
lève tôt vingt deux m3 cette patrouille
est conduite par le commandant alex
évolué en ski les pilotes des forces 0
spatiale font la démonstration d'une
opération extrêmement délicate qui
demande une grande précision
c'est le ravitaillement en vol d'un
bombardier stratégique tupolev 260
l'avion ravitailleur iliouchine il 62 18
et piloté par le commandant andré
perreault 6,9
le commandant de bord de taupo lève tôt
160 et du commandant andré pozdniakova
dans le ciel de moscou n'ont pas trop de
quatre chasseurs de supériorité aérienne
nick 29 mt qui sont modernisés sur les
autres de l'étang colonel guèye gaye des
diot
la formation suivante est composé de
quatre bombardiers tactiques de première
ligne
soukhoï sauve un 4ème qui sont conduits
par le lieutenant colonel germann anako
[Musique]
via ensuite une patrouille de chasseurs
intercepteurs supersonique à long rayon
d'action mig-31 cas c'est une version
modernisée qui est armé de missiles qui
ns à la composante redoutable de
dissuasion cette pas trop et placés sous
les ordres du commandant yevgeny ça lag
in vous voyez maintenant passer une
formation de quatre avions de combat
polyvalents de cinquième génération ce
qu i saw 57 conduite par le lieutenant
colonel vladimir volos cauvin dans le
ciel de moscou une patrouille tactiques
de combat qui comprennent 10 appareils
quatre bombardiers tactiques ce qu ils
sont 34 4 chasseurs polyvalents ce qu
ils sont 30 essais mais quatre chasseurs
polyvalents ce qu ils sont 35 s la
patrouille sur les ordres du colonel
youri grica ienco
et voici deux patrouilles aériennes
parmi les meilleurs du monde
comment des neuf appareils d russkie
vitiazi chevaliers russes et des stryges
ikki c'est-à-dire martinez sur cinq ce
qu ils sont 30 s m et 4 mig 29 qui
forment une figure qui est baptisée
diamant de cuenca le colonel andré
alexeyev adresse ses félicitations pour
ce jour de victoire à tous les citoyens
de la russie le défilé aérien s'achève
par le passage de six avions datacastle
ce qu il soit 20,5 sur le commandement
du colonel alexandre kotov que l'ess
dans le ciel de moscou
un panache composé de trois couleurs du
drapeau russe à savoir blanc bleu et
rouge m et voilà pour ce défilé aérien
qui comme le veut la tradition se
termine par ces fumées tricolore un
défilé militaire à minima puisque les
grandes festivités qui était
initialement prévu ont dû être annulés
en raison du corn un virus
le président russe tout à l'heure dans
son adresse à la nation l'a répété le
défilé militaire un cycle régiment
immortel seront bien
reporté à plus tard dans l'année sur
cette même place rouge où vous vous
trouvez antoine qu'est ce qui était
initialement prévu c'était une date
particulièrement importante cette année
puisqu'on célèbre le 75e anniversaire de
la victoire sur l'allemagne nazie en
russie où tout à fait les autorités
avaient vu les choses en grand et il y
avait beaucoup d'invités prestigieux des
invités des chefs d'état et autres
dignitaires étrangers on peut penser à
emmanuel macron qui avait confirmé sa
venue lors de l'invitation qui lui avait
été faite à brégançon l'année dernière
lors de la venue de vladimir poutine en
france le président chinois xi jinping
également été conviés et ainsi que
plusieurs autres dignitaires étrangers
et aux mots au niveau de la parade
militaire d'eads et des détachements de
militaires étrangers étaient également
prévu de défiler au kilo coûte et des
régiments russe alors bien sûr
aujourd'hui c'est une date un petit peu
particulière avec dans ce contexte de
coronavirus mais il est également le
régiment immortel et ça c'est une grosse
déception pour beaucoup de gens car
depuis quelques années ils ont pris
cette habitude de venir défiler avec le
portrait d'un proche d'un grand-père
d'un arrière-grand-père à la main pour
rendre hommage aux sacrifices faits par
des millions de citoyens soviétiques 27
millions de citoyens soviétiques qui se
sont sacrifiés pour cette victoire cette
victoire contre l'allemagne nazie et
d'arnaud antoine rapidement comment va
se dérouler le reste de la matinée dans
les prochaines heures prochaines minutes
[Musique]
eh bien vous admire encore une cérémonie
te prévu alors cette fois au sein du
kremlin quelque chose encore une fois de
créer dans un effectif très très
restreint comme cela était le cas
aujourd'hui comparé aux années
précédentes
autrement un peu plus tard dans la
journée il y aura une cérémonie
organisée au conseil de la fédération de
russie et les parlementaires reprendront
leur chanteront s'il est prévu que qu'il
chante la chanson du jour de la victoire
et puis bien sûr en fin de journée comme
c'est la tradition
un grand feu d'artifice dans la soirée
la coronavirus ou pas il aura bien lieu
merci antoine on retrouve claude
blanchemaison on vient de le rappeler
ces commémorations pour ce 75e
anniversaire de la victoire de la russie
sur l'allemagne nazie devait se dérouler
en grand c'est aussi un rendez vous
diplomatiques qu'elle quels échanges
étaient très attendus dans ce cadre je
crois que le fait que le président m'a
emmanuel macron et avait confirmé sa
présence est un élément important
pas très étonnant d'ailleurs parce que
comme vous le savez le général de gaulle
avait fait en sorte qu'une unité
combattante de l'aviation participent à
cette guerre avec l'armée rouge il
s'agit du fameux de la fameuse
escadrille normandie niémen on peut
d'ailleurs penser que comme ça s'est
déjà fait dans le passé
un détachement de la base de
mont-de-marsan qui porte la tradition de
normandie niemen pourrait aussi défilé à
l'occasion est en effet ces militaires
ces aviateurs français se sont battus
dans le ciel russes à l'époque et on a
battu plusieurs avions de l'allemagne
nazie par conséquent il ya une tradition
dans cet ensemble sur ce sujet une idée
française s'est battu avec les troupes
soviétique je note que dans son discours
d'entrée dans sa courte intervention le
président russe a salué l'exploit de
tous deux des soviétiques et aider
toutes les nationalités qui composent l
union s'inquiéter une scène nationalités
qui sont naturellement les kazakhes
les ukrainiens et biélorusses les
ouzbeks et beaucoup d'autres qui depuis
ils sont devenus indépendants donc cette
notation est aussi assez importante et
seppi
aujourd'hui devenus indépendants marque
évidemment l'anniversaire du neuf mais
également françois choisissiez du côté
des occidentaux on retient encore
aujourd'hui que les grands vainqueurs de
la seconde guerre mondiale sont les
américains on entend beaucoup moins
parler du rôle joué par la russie dans
la victoire contre l'allemagne nazie
comment est-ce qu'on vous l'expliquer je
pense que ces preuves de l'histoire on
voit toujours un petit plus qui se passe
à sa porte et pas un peu plus
lointainement ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point n'oublions pas quand
même que suite à cette deuxième guerre
mondiale le monde s'est divisée en deux
en europe
nous avions quand même un bloc de l'est
et un bloc de l'ouest et que je crois
que cet effacement plus ou moins
volontaire mais pas forcément de lin de
l'implication de l'union soviétique à
l'époque a été plus ou moins
idéologiquement me semble-t-il sans
doute est ignorée ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne la prend pas dans les livres
d'histoire les enfants les collégiens
apprennent cette histoire donc ya pas
une volonté délibérée d'effacer leurs
hôtes de l'ex union soviétique mais
néanmoins je pense que dans le collectif
c'est quand même un petit peu le
résultat de cette guerre froide qui a
fait qu'on n'a plus mis en valeur
l'occident d'un côté que l'ex union
soviétique et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
rétablit une certaine vérité de
l'histoire
chacun a pris sa part à cette guerre
tout le monde ya contribué à sa manière
avec le seul résultat obtenir c'était à
la destruction de l'état nazi et je
crois que c'est ce qu'ils étaient
obtenus et que je dirais qu'avec le
temps on revient qu'un juste équilibre
dans la compréhension de cette histoire
compliquée
et dernier combat à mener contre
l'allemagne nazie à la bataille de
berlin s'est soldé par la prise de la
ville par les soldats l'union soviétique
une victoire synonyme de capital de
capitulation des troupes allemandes
retour sur cette période de l'histoire
en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous les filles les signaleuse nous
allions nous reposer soudain nous avons
entendu des coups de feu effrayant
devant la porte
nous voulions nous cacher et tout à coup
la porte s'ouvre et notre signaleurs de
services nous créons et vous que faites
vous allongez la levée vous d'or c'est
la paix
[Musique]
et quel rôle a joué staline dans cette
seconde guerre mondiale l'historien jean
lopez revient sur le personnage il était
dans l'émission de frédéric taddeï
extraits d' interdit d'interdire et
italie mais alors on sait qu'il a fait
d'eux des erreurs considérables départ
notamment ne voulant pas croire jusqu'au
dernier moment que hitler allait
l'attaquer
est-ce qu'il s'est révélé un bon chef
militaire est ce qu'il a joué ce rôle là
d'abord oui il me suivait il n'a pas été
un bon chef militaire il a commis trop
d'erreurs pour qu'on puisse lui décerner
ce titre
en revanche en revanche il a été un bon
chef de guerre car il a su comme
personne d'autre probablement on aurait
su mobiliser le pays jusqu'à la dernière
goutte de sang est la dernière goutte de
sueur
on connaissait méthode je vais pas y
revenir ici mais j'insiste sur cette
différence
il n'est pas un grand chef militaire les
bêtises on pourrait parler jusqu'à
demain matin de ses erreurs que ce soit
barbarossa que ce soit l'encerclement de
kiev ce soit encore une fois l'erreur
sur la sur les attentions allemande de
mai 42 qui avait rivka mène au désastre
de kharkov
il a multiplié les bévues c'est
incontestable il a souvent été une gêne
mais pas seulement
alors comme khrouchtchev avait eu
khrouchtchev à prétendre à hautmont du
20ème congrès qui savent même pas lire
une carte
évidemment c'est absurde comme hitler
c'est un homme qui comprend comme saison
fichiers du bas il comprend parfaitement
ce qu'on lui dit mais c'est pas son
domaine les opérations il est sûr le
jour 1 les rapports de la staf cas le
staff gaëtan le staff car c'est staline
son petit état major personnel tous les
jours il est en rapport au téléphone ou
par télex avec les chefs de front avec
les représentants spéciaux de la star
cas tous les jours
a part ça le reste du temps et la nuit
eh bien il va gérer l'effort de guerre
il a son petit carré dans lequel il
nomme le nombre le nombre d'avions le
nombre de chars qui sont produits iman
la diplomatie il est absolument partout
où j'écris quelque part avec l'achat
dans d'autres
son barbarossa que l'union soviétique a
failli perdre la guerre à cause de lui
mais qui ne pouvait pas la gagner sans
lui
un clown blanchemaison qu'elle était
quels chefs militaires et et staline a
selon vous à vos yeux
ben je crois qu'en tout cas le peuple
russe aujourd'hui lui reconnaît d'avoir
été capable de tenir tenir notamment
pendant le siège de stalingrad qui a été
un siège extrêmement meurtrier est
également pendant le siège de leningrad
et pendant le siège bien entendu de
moscou a pas tout ça n'était pas évident
de tenir aussi longtemps avec des pertes
aussi importante du côté soviétique
et je rappelle que à l'époque où moscou
a été assiégé le gouvernement soviétique
avait prévu avait déjà installé
d'ailleurs un repli dans la ville de
kobe tu chef sur la volga qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui la ville de samarra et
impôts ebit chef on avait installé
d'ailleurs un pc de commandement pour
staline à 50 mètres sous terre que l'on
visite encore aujourd'hui certaines
ambassades s'était déjà replié aquabeat
chef parce que on n'était pas sûr que
moscou puisse tenir le siège et c'est la
volonté de staline qui a fait que les
troupes ont pu ont pu tenir
je crois que c'est cela que aujourd'hui
les russes reconnaissent à staline alors
comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure
bien entendu sur le plan militaire il
faut faire le partage entre les chefs
militaires qui avaient leur propre
stratégie et leur tactique à mettre en
oeuvre et puis les instructions que
pouvait leur donner un staline mais en
tout cas les instructions de staline
était toujours de tenir et vous françois
je pense y est vous qui est un général
de brigade comment est ce que vous voyez
installez nord en tant que chef
militaire va effectivement je rejoins ce
qui vient d'être dit un chef militaire
sûrement pas chef de guerre sûrement je
crois quand même que les pertes en
hommes ont été terribles et aussi parce
que l'humain n'a pas été considéré comme
un humain y compris par staline comme il
fallait tenir comme ça vient d'être
appelé il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
scrupules à faire tuer des milliers
d'hommes dans des assauts parfois dignes
de la première guerre mondiale
mais il fallait tenir donc chef de
guerre
oui parce que un homme politique doit
être capable de tenir maintenant
reconnaissons quand même que le système
soviétique que permettait difficilement
à l'opposition quelle qu'elle soit et
compris de députés par exemple de
s'opposer à la guerre et de demander la
paix donc je crois que le régime
totalitaire de staline qui ne faut pas
quand même négligé a permis que l'armée
tienne et que le peuple tienne parce que
il faut un chef fort dans une crise
bon maintenant les moyens qui ont été
utilisés c'est à dire des pertes
humaines énorme ont apporté la victoire
alors après l'histoire jugera
on constate aujourd'hui que pour le
peuple russes staline a quand même été
un homme d'importance dans son histoire
et qui a permis finalement aujourd'hui à
la russie d'exister et je crois que
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir
malgré tous les aléas d'une guerre dont
on n'est jamais m haies les américains
font a présentés comme les grands
vainqueurs de la seconde guerre mondiale
une réécriture de l'histoire pour
beaucoup tant abonnés quand on parle du
dénouement de la seconde guerre mondiale
beaucoup ont en tête les images du
débarquement anglo saxons sur les plages
de normandie une opération militaire
certes importante pour vaincre l'ennemi
nazi mais qui occulte le front de l'est
particulièrement déterminant plus
généralement lorsque l'on demande aux
français quelle nation a le plus
contribué à la défaite de l'allemagne en
1945 une majorité répond que ce sont les
états unis dans les données fournies par
l'ifop
une étude est particulièrement frappante
un tableau comparatif qui recense des
enquêtes d'opinion réalisé 2
1945 à mai 2015 on y voit clairement
qu'à la sortie de la guerre l'opinion
française reconnaît majoritairement le
rôle prépondérant de l'armée rouge
57% des sondés de l'époque font de
l'urss le pays qui a le plus contribué à
la défaite de l'allemagne les etats-unis
ne sont alors cité que par 20 % des
sondés cette étude montre que 70 ans
plus tard les courbes se sont
complètement inversé les états unis sont
cités par une majorité pour leur rôle
prépondérant dans la victoire face au
troisième reich
alors comment expliquer un tel
changement pour annie lacroix-riz
professeur émérite d'histoire
contemporaine à paris 7
l'enseignement de l'histoire au collège
et au lycée peut expliquer ce revirement
de la perception du dénouement de la
guerre 39 45 il y à lui redit ce sens en
janvier 1980 5 dans la revue historiens
et géographes un extraordinaire article
d'une politique américaine qui s'appelle
diana pinto elle avait analysé en
janvier 1985
la nouvelle fournée des manuels
scolaires du secondaire et elle disait
la sauce suivante elle disait c'est
parfait les historiens sont en train de
basculer
nous avons des manuels d'histoire qui
sont satisfaisants pour pour nous vous
regardez aujourd'hui d'emmanuel je
n'enseigne plus ça fait longtemps que je
n'enseigne plus glisser mais j'ai des
petits-enfants dans les petites classes
je te constatait en effet qu' on a une
présentation historiographique qui est
une véritable violation de la vérité
historique il faut bien le dire si
l'incontournable bataille de stalingrad
est enseignée force est de constater que
le rôle de l'urss et peut-être
sous-évalué dans les manuels scolaires
de l'hexagone et ce alors qu'on le
rappelle l'union soviétique est le pays
qui a payé le plus lourd tribut en
termes de nombre
deux morts pas question d'entrer dans un
funeste concours mais les 26 millions de
soviétiques dont environ 15 millions de
soldats qui ont perdu la vie illustre
tristement l'implication de l'urss dans
le combat contre les troupes d'adolphe
hitler
si les états unis apparaissent
aujourd'hui comme les vainqueurs tout
désigné aux yeux d'une majorité de
français ils le doivent aussi à leur
influence culturelle en europe à travers
des films à gros budget hollywood
contribue à vanter les exploits des gi's
en mettant en lumière le conflit sous un
angle unique
si ces productions n'ont pas vocation à
se substituer aux récits historiques
on peut facilement supposer qu'elles ont
un impact non négligeable dans
l'imaginaire collectif des spectateurs
enfin on peut aussi expliquer cette
perception par des biais géopolitique
car la guerre froide a peut-être laissé
des traces des rivalités on peut
empêcher une transmission historique
fidèle aux événements dans leur
globalité
de nos jours encore commémoration et
célébration historique se heurte parfois
des postures diplomatiques en 2015 pour
les 70 ans de la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale ni françois hollande ni
anglais la merkel ne s'était rendu à
moscou pour la parade militaire du 9 mai
2020 devait marquer un apaisement
puisque de nombreux chefs d'état avaient
annoncé leur présence dans la capitale
russe ces locaux vides 19 on a décidé
autrement on ne peut qu'espérer que des
cérémonies partager puisse rééquilibrer
le poids de chacun dans l'histoire avec
un grand h
le clown blanc de maison rappelez-nous
un peu l'état des forces au lendemain de
la seconde guerre mondiale
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
cette domination américaine à quoi
est-ce qu'elle est due à bannu doute que
nous nous parlions ce matin c'est
évidemment la fin de la guerre en or
c'est à dire la chute du nazisme mais ça
n'est pas tout à fait la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale puisque comme
vous savez les opérations militaires ont
continué pendant un certain temps au
dans le pacifique en asie pour venir à
bout du régime militariste japonais et à
ce titre d'ailleurs
l'union soviétique avait des
conversations avec les japonais qui
essayait de maintenir l'union soviétique
en dehors de ce conflit dans le
pacifique
et puis finalement les soviétiques mais
assez tardivement sont des rangs sont
entrés en guerre contre le japon en
envahissant le mode soupault la partie
nord de la corée et toute une partie de
cette région les îles kouriles également
le sud de sakhaline et effectivement on
était le 2 septembre à la signature à la
cérémonie de signature de la reddition
du japon
pour revenir à votre question et à la
situation des forces au lendemain de la
signature de la reddition sans
conditions de l'allemagne nazie donc le
9 mai 1945
évidemment en europe et bien il y avait
eu la conférence de yalta auparavant et
à yalta en effet les grands de ce monde
c'était un peu partagé les zones
d'affluence en europe et elle et les
staline et le président américain où les
stones churchill avait tracé des lignes
sur une carte de l'europe pour dessiner
le partage des zones d'affluence
le général de gaulle a toujours contesté
cette façon de faire puisque la france
libre n'était pas ay alta et en effet il
là il l'a fait savoir
alors effectivement comme vous le savez
le général de gaulle avait d'ailleurs
effectué un voyage tout à fait épique en
union soviétique dès 1944 pour signer un
accord à un accord avec staline il a eu
d'ailleurs beaucoup de mal à le signer
mais finalement cet accord a été signé
et il a marqué en effet que la france
libre est l interlocuteur valable
alors le rapport des forces il est
dans les pays de la partie occidentale
de l'europe
c'était évidemment les états unis
d'amérique qui domine et qui d'ailleurs
ont leurs troupes eu un peu partout et
puis dans la partie orientale de cette
europe
et bien c'est l'union soviétique c'est
la conséquence de galles pas et de l'
équilibre où des opérations militaires
et on va retourner retourner tout de
suite sur la place rouge de moscou avec
vous antoine d'un clairon on a vécu il
ya quelques instants cette cérémonie on
a vu le président russe vladimir poutine
à déposé une gerbe de fleurs près de là
de la flamme éternelle le président
russe qui s'est adressé à la nation
rappelons notamment l'importance et
spirituelle de ce jour de la victoire
oui tout à fait l'importance spirituel
de ce jour de la victoire mais aussi cet
esprit de sacrifice de tout un peuple
pour pouvoir repousser repousser la
menace la menace nazie
loin de ses frontières je vous propose
d'écouter un morceau la fin de
l'allocution de vladimir poutine
ils ont combattu contre la mort pour la
vie et nous nous alignons sur leur
dignité
nous sommes réunis dans cette histoire
dans cet espoir dans ses aspirations
la responsabilité pour le présent et
pour l'avenir nos savons et nous avons
cette assurance que nous sommes
investies invincible quand nous sommes
ensemble
bonne fête bon jour de la victoire pour
alors à la suite de cette allocution du
président russe il n'y a pas eu le
traditionnel de traditionnel défilé
militaire sur la place rouge
quant à virus oblige mais à la place le
volet aérien était conservée et 75
appareils 20 hélicoptères et 55 avions
militaires ont survolé la place rouge
avec les derniers appareils avec les
sens une traîne blanche rouge et bleu
aux couleurs de la russie
merci antoine et cette histoire à
présent celle de deux soeurs séparés
pendant la bataille de stalingrad en
1942 après soixante dix huit années de
recherche elles se sont finalement
retrouvés cette année et elle témoigne
[Musique]
après le début du bombardement amer avec
la sienne olga il isna et avec gaia on
commence à enquêter sur le sort de rosa
elle ne savait pas qu'elle était rescapé
elles ont vu ces ruines après le
bombardement et on leur a dit qu rosa
était morte quand est fier il bombe
était tombé directement sur l'atelier où
elle travaillait
[Musique]
il y avait ni pai vidéo je ne croyais
pas que tous mes proches étaient morts
je n'y croyais pas quelque chose en nous
for intérieur ne me permettait pas
d'accepter l'idée que tout le monde
était mort la jeune fille au mieux les
j'ai commencé à chercher j'ai commencé à
écrire
la réponse est négative [ __ ] 2005
on nous répondait ne rien savoir sur ces
personnes quoi ni atout ni attaquer
elle a contacté un centre d'appels et on
lui a dit oui nous avons une telle
demande quelqu'un a cherché en 2014 mais
maintenant cette demande n'est plus
d'actualité
quelques jours après ma soeur a
recommencé à se renseigner
pourriez vous me dire au moins sait dans
quelles régions de la russie
ils ont dit que c'était peut-être dans
la région de tcheliabinsk
c'est tout point une fois de plus ils
n'ont rien dit
[Rires]
[Musique]
en discutant avec cette personne
sa voix était si plein d'espoir et de la
conviction qu'elle pouvait être en vie
elle m'a tout simplement demandé de la
trouver j'ai voulu l'aider en tant
qu'être humain tout simplement
et j'ai continué à chercher poste
[Musique]
doucement du calme doucement pourquoi
nous tiens
[Musique]
oh
je crois que les autres pareils sont
rarissimes
ces cieux j'étais sûr que quelqu'un
avait une idée que je tenais pas
possible que tout le monde soit mort non
ce n'est pas
il fallait que quelqu'un survie je
remercie tous ceux qui l'ont aidé à
retrouver ma soeur rose à on parle
françois chavance et de l'héroïsme des
soldats soviétiques hitler entendeur on
le rappelle anéantir l'urss notamment
pour y piller les matières premières et
les populations l'ont un très durement
payé à tout à fait et on peut être que
comment dire surpris mais par le courage
du soldat russe soviétique parce que
c'est vrai qu'il n'y avait pas que des
russes
la volonté de se battre jusqu'au bout
mais je répète quand je dis tout à
l'heure il y avait quand même un système
autoritaire derrière qui permettait
difficilement aux soldats russes de se
rebeller ou de ne pas faire la guerre il
faut quand même pas l'oublier
maintenant il est indéniable que tout ce
qu'on peut lire sur cette guerre
patriotique a montré que le soldat
soviétique était patriotes ils défendent
est sa terre ils défendent et sa famille
il ne défendrait pas forcément le régime
mais c'était vraiment une guerre
d'agression qui subissaient et que je
crois que ce cette réflexion sur
l'engagement du soldat qui n'était pas
que professionnel mérite d'être souligné
nous avons des gens qui se sont battus
jusqu'à la mort sans état d'âme et pour
amener cette victoire et ce qui explique
les pertes phénoménales qui a subi l'une
aux soviétiques et je crois que cette
réflexion de cette guerre du passé doit
se réfléchir aujourd'hui vous avez
évoqué par votre reportage tout à
l'heure cette historienne qui évoque les
ouvrages en france sur historique sur
l'histoire et c'est fait en france la
notion de guerre aujourd'hui est quand
même une notion qui est éloigné parler
de la guerre patriotique de l'union
soviétique tous ces morts toute cette
guerre atroce ce n'est pas dans l'air du
temps et ce qui explique pourquoi les
livres d'histoire finalement édulcore en
partie ce l'implication de l'union
soviétique n'est pas uniquement tous nos
livres d'histoire refuse
hier or la guerre c'est l'engagement de
l'individu d'une collectivité face à une
menace grave et je crois que ce que
cette commémoration 75e anniversaire
montre bien cet engagement total qu'un
peuple peut avoir face à une menace sur
sa survie et des mots pour réconforter
soutenir ou tout simplement on dire
merci dans le cadre de notre projet
courier de la victoire arte france vous
donne l'occasion d'adresser une lettre à
aux combattants de la seconde guerre
mondiale elles seront transmises aux
vétérans
j'ai beaucoup d'amis
[Musique]
qui est prise jean baillet
la jambe
je n'ai jamais pleuré
on était des deux hommes
[Musique]
non non
et maintenant
[Musique]
tu
mon discours au soir
[Musique]
et
et la russie célèbre le 75e anniversaire
de la victoire sur l'allemagne nazie
édition spéciale nous suivrons en direct
ces commémorations depuis la place rouge
de moscou
si les occidentaux célèbrent la victoire
de la seconde guerre mondiale par les
alliés le 8 mai c'est le lendemain le 9
mai que les russes fait ce jour la fin
de ce qui est nommé en russie la grande
guerre patriotique la reddition
l'allemagne s'est faite en deux temps un
premier acte de capitulation signé à
reims a pris effet le 8 mai 1945
mais la reddition définitive sera
paraphé à berlin au qg soviétique
peu après minuit le 9 mai ce qui
explique donc ces décalages et le rubans
de saint-georges que nous portons tous à
l'antenne aujourd'hui via le symbolisme
la lutte du peuple russe contre le
nazisme
un hommage aux quelque 25 millions de
soviétiques et qui ont un trouvé la mort
des commémorations initialement prévu en
grand pour ce 75e anniversaire cette
année
plusieurs hauts dirigeants étaient
invités à moscou pour l'occasion et mais
quand un virus oblige les festivités ont
dû être repoussés seuls ont été
maintenus des vols d'avions militaires
ils ont survolé tout à l'heure la place
rouge de moscou vous l'avez vécu en
direct sur notre antenne
le défilé militaire lui devrait se tenir
plus tard dans l'année vladimir poutine
l'a confirmé nous retrouvons à tout de
suite notre correspondant à moscou
antoine claireaux antoine elle c'est une
célébration à minima qui s'est donc
déroulée racontez nous
une célébration à minima là je me trouve
en ce moment sur la place rouge qui
normalement un 9 mai traditionnel est
complètement noir de monde là sur le
côté de la place normalement se trouvent
les tribunes qui accueillent les
nombreux chefs d'état qui font le
déplacement cette année aurait dû se
trouver entre autres le président
chinois xi jinping ou encore le
président français emmanuel macron qui
avait été invité par vladimir poutine
moment de sa visite au fort de brégançon
au mois d'août dernier de mes donc
coronavirus oblige
rien de tout cela cette année seul le
seul le volet aérien de cette parade
militaire a été maintenu avec 75
appareils 20 hélicoptères et 55 avions
qui ont survolé cette place rouge
merci antoine parmi les personnalités
qui étaient initialement annoncée pour
célébrer à moscou cet anniversaire de la
victoire sur l'allemagne avait emmanuel
macron claude blanchemaison c'est
finalement par téléphone que vladimir
poutine s'est entretenu avec emmanuel
macron hier le président russe qui a
évoqué la coopération entre la russie et
la france le président français a lui
insisté sur l'importance du dialogue
stratégique entre paris et moscou est
cela se traduit comment aujourd'hui
concrètement le réchauffement des
relations franco russes
je crois que c'est dans la nature des
choses
encore une fois comme je voulais dit la
france libre en tout cas a repris sa
part dans le combat de l'armée rouge
contre le nazisme est d'ailleurs
j'aurais dû dire tout à l'heure à propos
de stalingrad à dégrader l'une des
seules villes étrangères
titulaire de la décoration de la légion
d'honneur qui lui a été accordé par le
général de gaulle lui-même
donc il ya ces liens il ya toute la
tradition de normandie niémen
aussi quand je les dis également tout à
l'heure et puis aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de coopération entre la russie
et la france et même entre la russie et
l'europe en dépit des zones de désaccord
il peut y avoir des zones de désaccord
cela n'empêche pas de coopérer sur
beaucoup de sujets vous savez que un
certain nombre de fusées russes sont
lancés depuis le pas de tir de kourou
qui est un pas de tir en guyane
française qui n'a pas tiré européens et
que ceux ci permet en effet de lancer
des satellites avec des fusées russes à
partir d'un pâtir européen et français
puisque c'est en guyane française
il ya également beaucoup dé change
naturellement entre les responsables
politiques entre les responsables
économiques avec la france c'est quand
même l'un des premiers investisseurs en
russie et que les entreprises françaises
ne sont pas repartis lorsqu'il ya eu une
petite une brouille politique
elles sont toujours là et les ministres
des affaires économiques se rencontrent
chaque année mais en effet les ministres
de la défense et des affaires étrangères
en formation à quatre se sont également
rencontrés c'était une des conclusions
de brégançon lier et ces discussions
continuent et continuent aussi à des
niveaux plus technique avec des
conversations entre responsables
militaires parce que en effet il ya
beaucoup de sujets à discuter quelles
que soient les sujets de désaccord et
puis et puis
la france a accueilli 9 décembre une un
sommet en format normandie comme on dit
pour essayer de régler la question du
nom basse effectivement c'est très
difficile puisqu'il ya une guerre qui a
fait 14 mille morts dans le donbass et
en ukraine et que par conséquent ceci va
prendre un peu de temps
mais cette ce règlement est en cours
entre européens et je pense que en effet
le président poutine comme le prétend
macron ont à coeur de résoudre ce
problème
la chancelière merkel également et le
président et l'inscrit à kiev aussi à
l'arrière évidemment chacun a fêté
j'allais dire dans son coin à cause de
l'épidémie d'e coronavirus la fête de la
victoire à londres ce si ça a été
marquée par une minute de silence
euh pas à lourdes mais dans tout le
royaume uni à 11 heures du matin heure
du royaume uni et puis le soir hier soir
la reine la reine elizabeth a fait un
discours assez émouvant parce que ya 75
ans elle avait 18 ans elle était à côté
de son père georges 6 au balcon de
buckingham et elle été
exceptionnellement autorisés à sortir
dans l'ombre pour fêter la victoire avec
le peuple anglais et elle a rappelé ses
souvenirs son père sa soeur la fête de
la victoire le fait qu'elle avait
qu'elle s'était engagée volontaire comme
infirmière parce que bien entendu nombre
a beaucoup souffert des bombardements de
l'allemagne nazie donc je pense que avec
la pandémie qui fait finalement
réfléchir tout le monde sur ce qui est
vrai véritablement important dans la vie
je pense que les conditions certaines
conditions sont probablement réunis pour
en effet une réconciliation européenne
et dans les manuels d'histoire en france
le rôle de la russie dans l'effort
militaire de la seconde guerre mondiale
et la victoire contre le nazisme et peu
mis en valeur par rapport aux états unis
écoutez à ce sujet les explications de
l'historienne annie lacroix-riz j'ai été
enseignante j'ai été professeur des
universités à partir de 84 85
et j'ai donc enseigner dans le
secondaire jusqu'en jusque fin 84 certes
ce que vous évoquez je dirais faisait
l'objet d'une
de ce que j'appellerais de la propagande
des grands médias
mais nous avions des manuels du
secondaire en tout cas il en existait
dans mon lycée
on en avait un excellent qui était celui
jam bouillon il est clair que il
existait encore une présentation honnête
de la chose ce qui n'existe plus du tout
je n'enseigne plus et ça fait longtemps
que je n'enseigne plus glisser mais j'ai
des petits-enfants dans les petites
classes
je te constatait en effet qu' on a une
présentation historiographique qui est
une véritable violation de la vérité
historique il faut bien le dire mais ça
nous amène évidemment une conjoncture
rapport de force tels que l'histoire
faite par les archives et notamment
l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale ont été révisés mais révisé au
moins au mauvais sens du terme c'est à
dire que on n'a plus du tout nos élèves
et nos étudiants n'ont plus du tout dans
les pays occidentaux car ce qui arrive à
la france arrive à l'échelle de l'union
européenne des états unis etc
il est impossible aujourd'hui d'avoir
une idée est bien entendu il sait
favoriser par toute une série
d'émissions de télévision et cetera il
est aujourd'hui impossible d'avoir une
image par exemple qui correspondent à
des choses aussi simples aussi
élémentaires que ce que je vous ai
évoqué au début c'est à dire par exemple
la simple correspondance entre staline
et churchill où s'alignent pas son temps
à partir de l'été 1941 à réclamer cette
fameuse ouverture du second front de
temps en temps finit par se fâcher sur
tille lui promettent
tous les tous les mois tous les
trimestres
tous les semestres que le second front
est pour bientôt et sa ligne se
plaignant il faut bien le dire tout à
fait légitime band soviétique sont
toujours seuls à batailler contre la
wehrmacht et dernier combat à mener
contre l'allemagne nazie la bataille de
berlin s'est soldé par la prise de la
ville par les soldats de l'union
soviétique
une victoire synonyme de capitulation
des troupes allemandes
retour en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se bat et mai
nous les filles les signaleuse nous
allions nous reposer soudain nous avons
entendu des coups de feu effrayant
devant la porte
nous voulions nous cacher et tout à coup
la porte s'ouvre et notre signaleurs de
services nous créons et vous que faites
vous allongez la levée vous d'or c'est
la paix
[Musique]
françois chossy vadimir poutine s'est
adressé à la nation tout à l'heure comme
le veut la tradition après avoir déposé
une gerbe de fleurs près de la flamme
éternelle un bref discours prononcé
devant la flamme du soldat inconnu pour
marquer on le rappelle la défaite de
l'allemagne nazie
il a notamment déclaré que la russie
était invincible lorsqu'elle était une
et comment est ce que vous avez
accueilli ce propos cet art à propos de
circonstance je crois que vladimir
poutine est dans son rôle de magnifier
les sacrifices passés en l'occurrence du
peuple russe ce même si l'associé des
autres peuples de l'ex union soviétique
je crois que c'est les paroles normale
d'un chef politique des décideurs
politiques et je trouve que c'est une
très bonne chose de le rappeler mais
c'est valable pour tous les pays y
compris à l'époque du coronavirus quand
il ya une menace le peuple doit être
unie derrière ses dirigeants même si des
erreurs sont fait même si on n'est pas
forcément d'accord contient de crise
grave
il faut se rassembler je crois que c'est
le peux je dirais le principe de tout
groupe humain face à la menace
on reste unis derrière celui qui nous
guide alors je dis pas que vladimir
poutine et le guide suprême je n'oserais
pas allé jusqu'à la cie simplement que
il n'incarne l'état russe et s'approprie
l'histoire de l'ex union soviétique pour
bien souligner aujourd'hui c'est la
réappropriation de l'histoire de l'ex
union soviétique qui l'intègre dans
l'histoire russe ce qui me semble
d'ailleurs personnellement assez
légitime et le message qu'il a passés me
semble tout à fait cohérent avec la
place qui veut tenir
alors comment expliquer aujourd'hui la
domination américaine après la victoire
des alliés pour l'historienne année
lacroix riz cela s'explique par leur
domination économique sur une union
soviétique
accablé par les pertes on écoute une
guerre bien entendu ça passe par un
préalable
le préalable c'est la victoire militaire
mais une guerre n'est pas qu'une
victoire militaire
une guerre est aussi sinon alors que la
condition je dirais sinéquanone c'est
bien entendu la situation militaire
elle et son bilan est le résultat de ce
fameux rapport des forces est ce rapport
des forces
nul n'ignore depuis aux fêtes 1940 que
compte tenu de la puissance économique
et financière des états unis ce sont les
états unis qui en seront les vainqueurs
et quand vous travailler là dessus vous
vous rendez bien compte parce que la
chronologie est toujours un élément roi
vous vous rendez bien compte que la
question de la terreur de lure c'est une
question qu'il ne s'est jamais
réellement posé la question qui s'est
réellement posée c'était de savoir si
l'angleterre pourrait considérer
pourrait conserver une partie de sa
superbe
il a été démontré entre 1945 et 1947 et
au delà mais pour l'essentiel entre 1945
et 1947 qu'elle n'était plus qu'un
partenaire second
comme l'a dit un secrétaire d'état
américain exxon et il a été démontré à
partir de 1945 mais sur la base de
projets de guerre que les états unis
étaient en mesure de reconquérir ce
qu'ils avaient dû de fait accepter
notamment à yalta et potsdam
c'est à dire ces fameux accords avec
l'union soviétique qui n'avait pas voulu
négocier pendant la guerre pour une
raison très simple c'est que roosevelt
savez très bien et pas seulement trop
roosevelt et truman savez très bien que
l'union soviétique a tablé par les
pertes extrêmement appauvri en quelque
sorte l'idée serait incapable
une fois les armes abandonnées de
profiter de sa victoire militaire et
claude blanchemaison vous êtes expert en
relations internationales après ce
propos de cette historienne comment et
russe à vos yeux l'ordre international
at il évolué dans l'après guerre
après 1945 oui évidemment puisqu'on a
connu la guerre froide est ce qu'on a
appelé un monde bipolaire pendant toute
cette période de la guerre froide
ce monde est révolu édile est révolu
après la chute de l'union soviétique
tant qu'il y avait 2 2 quand un monde
bipolaire les deux camps n'était pas
simplement en rivalités géopolitiques il
était en rivalité totale puisque
c'étaient deux systèmes idéologiques qui
s'affrontaient chacun voulant affirmer
sa supériorité sur l'autre ce temps-là
est terminée il n'y a plus d'union
soviétique et plus personne en russie ne
se réfèrent sérieusement à un système
communiste
la russie est une économie de marché
elle fait partie d'ailleurs de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
de toutes les organisations
internationales voulu et bien entendu
ses dirigeants sont très attachés à
l'économie de marché
j'allais même dire au hawk système
capitaliste même parfois avec félix est
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
monde multipolaire et la question est de
savoir quels sont les principaux pôles
et quels sont ceux dont la puissance
augmente et quels sont ceux dont la
puissance diminue naturellement tout le
monde constate aujourd'hui
la montée de la puissance chinoise et
c'est ça le nouveau problème en effet
pour tous les autres pays c'est à dire
pour tous les autres pôles pour les
américains on le voit dans la façon dont
donald trump traite delà de la sphère
chinoise mais on le voit aussi dans lé
cad que peut avoir
l'amp par rapport aux investissements
chinois par rapport aux routes de la
soie et bien sûr nous restons tous amis
de la chine mais plus personne n'est
naïf vis à vis de la chine
mais vis-à-vis de ce land saussez
entreprise en tant que deuxième
puissance économique du monde pour
prendre toute sa place sur le plan
politique sur le plan géostratégique et
aussi sur le plan militaire
c'est aussi valable pour la russie et
nous retrouvons à présent notre
correspondant antoine clairon en direct
de moscou antoine d'habitude des
millions de russes défilent en
brandissant les portraits des membres de
leur famille qui ont participé à la
seconde guerre mondiale ils défilent
dans la foulée de cette scène lorsque
président veut se déposent une gerbe de
fleurs il s'adresse ensuite à la nation
il y à ce défilé militaire qui
aujourd'hui s'est résumée à ce défilé
aérien l'on puisse régiment immémoriale
année ils ont trouvé cette année une
autre solution
oui tout à fait à l'arrêt en raison des
commandes yard et du confinement des
conséquences de la propagation du corps
d'un virus
il a fallu trouver une autre solution et
cette solution était un site internet
dédié ainsi tout un chacun peut poster
une photo ou à défaut un message qui
rend hommage aux à tous et soviétiques
morts pendant 1 7 seconde guerre
mondiale donc un site internet dédié
auquel safer plus de 4000 volontaires à
travers tout le pays qui recueille tous
ces messages toutes ces photos j'ai pu
également voir sur mon chemin vers la
place rouge
postés aux fenêtres des portraits mais
aussi aux fenêtres de véhicules deux
voitures et autres taxis ces portraits
de parole de proches de grands pères
d'art et un grand-père qui ont combattu
ou qui ont participé à l'effort de
guerre durant cette grande guerre
patriotique alors pour rappel cette
marche du régiment immortel a été à une
été initié en 2012 dans la ville de
tomsk en russie et qui n'a eu de cesse
de gagner en popularité au fil des
années pour devenir ce qu'il est devenu
ces dernières années c'est à dire un
immense événement qui rassemble des
millions de personnes 1 million de
personnes à moscou l'année dernière et
plusieurs autres millions à travers
toutes les autres villes russes du truc
les autres villes du pays
merci antoine et cette histoire à
présent celle de deux soeurs séparés
pendant la bataille de stalingrad en 42
après soixante dix huit années de
recherche elles se sont finalement
retrouvés cette année et elle témoigne
[Musique]
après le début des bombardements amer
avec la sienne olga willis n'a et avec
gaillard on commence à enquêter sur le
sort de rosa elle ne savait pas qu'elle
était rescapé
ils ont vu ces ruines après le
bombardement et on leur a dit qu rosa
était morte etc en est fier il bombe
était tombé directement sur l'atelier où
elle travaillait
[Musique]
il ya eu ni payet déroule au je ne
croyais pas que tous mes proches étaient
morts je n'y croyais pas quelque chose
dans mon for intérieur ne me permettait
pas d'accepter l'idée que tout le monde
était mort la jeune fille au mieux les
j'ai commencé à chercher j'ai commencé à
écrire
la réponse était négative [ __ ] 2005 on
me répondait ne rien savoir sur ces
personnes quoi ni attaquer
elle a contacté un centre d'appels et on
lui a dit oui nous avons une telle
demande quelqu'un a cherché en 2014 mais
maintenant cette demande n'est plus
d'actualité
quelques jours après ma soeur a
recommencé à se renseigner
pourriez vous me dire au moins sait dans
quelles régions de la russie
ils ont dit que c'était peut-être dans
la région de tcheliabinsk
c'est au point une fois de plus ils
n'ont rien dit
[Rires]
[Musique]
en discutant avec cette personne sa voix
était si plein d'espoir et de la
conviction qu'elle pouvait être en vie
elle m'a tout simplement demandé de la
trouver j'ai voulu l'aider en tant
qu'être humain tout simplement
et j'ai continué à chercher presque
[Musique]
doucement du calme doucement
je crois que les rencontres pareils sont
rarissimes
ces cieux j'étais sûr que quelqu'un
vision vie que je ce n'est pas possible
que tout le monde soit mon rôle non ce
n'est pas possible il fallait que
quelqu'un survivre je remercie tous ceux
qui l'ont aidé à retrouver ma soeur rose
à 9 mai l'occasion de revenir sur des
témoignages poignants survivants de la
seconde guerre mondiale
chez l'homo selinger est lui un ancien
prisonnier du camp de concentration de
terezin enfants installés par les nazis
près la frontière avec la
tchécoslovaquie
il raconte j'étais en commun et je t'ai
mis parmi les morts d'indochine médecins
et de l'armée rouge a probablement
regarder et l'adulte hihi je n'y suis
pas tout à fait mort il m'a enlevé parmi
les morts elle met notre qualité
d'afghans l'eau l'hôpital de campagne
militaire soviétique et il s'acharnait
pour me rendre la ville
[Musique]
pour nous sommes sortis de la maison et
on nous a dit tant dans ses rues dans un
ghetto où quelqu'un cinq maisons ont été
créés tous insulter notre style une
partie des sommes des juifs étaient
envoyés tout de suite par à en suisse
dans des camps où ils étaient hébergés à
sa fille et parlait d'âge
et tandis que nous on nous envoyait en
allemagne o'shea nous étions au chili
aucun des six n'est d'être assassiné
mais par le travail
[Musique]
j'ai passé avec compensation des
composants consommation différente car
les concentrations où j'étais à grosses
roses et social pour les paysages autour
cet instrument de montagne très très
beau et la beauté je détestais la beauté
vers la fin de la guerre ma part ma
deuxième marche de la mort je suis animé
a très vite
[Musique]
j'espère que de recevoir son nom pouvoir
le co aurait eu ces cochons fichiers et
j ai exprimé ma main à l'armée à l'armée
rouge qui est pas seulement ce qui à qui
un le combattu et avec des grands
sacrifices dit l armée nagy néophytes
qui il climatique qui grâce à eux les
deux sujets je suis ce que je suis
vivant et entre derniers mois avec vous
françois chavance y est on le rappelle
la seconde guerre mondiale a fait plus
de 25 millions lors en urss est un bilan
extrêmement lourd coût de la moitié des
victimes
oui tout à fait mais je crois qu'on a eu
à l'est le front oriental comme on
l'appelait une guerre presque
civilisationnel entre d'un côté le
peuple entre guillemets germanique je
pèse mes mots et le peuple slave
c'était le retour de l'histoire un
rappelez-vous les chevaliers teutoniques
à une autre époque
donc on était bien dans une guerre à
outrance et sans grand respect des
droits humains vous venez de passer un
reportage justement ce ces rescapés des
camps de la mort mais je crois aussi que
les soldats soviétiques ont été aussi
très mal traités quand ils ont été faits
prisonniers
je crois qu'il faut pas l'oublier et que
cette guerre à outrance cette guerre
totale peut être a fait qu'on n'a pas
respecté les droits humains qu'on a
massacré les gens sans aucun état d'âme
sans sans respecter finalement le droit
de la guerre en tant que tel et je crois
que c'est ce que nous rappelle cette
guerre et le grand sacrifice humain
accepté par l'union soviétique
merci à beaucoup françois achevant si je
rappelle que vous êtes un général de
brigade et expert en géostratégie merci
à vous aussi claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales merci à
tous les deux d'avoir
de nous avoir accompagnés ce moment pour
vivre en direct à ces commémorations
depuis et la place rouge de moscou des
mots pour réconforter pour soutenir ou
tout simplement pour dire merci
dans le cadre de notre projet courier de
la victoire rt france vous donne
l'occasion d'adresser une lettre aux
combattants de la seconde guerre
mondiale elles seront transmises aux
vétérans et c'est la fin de cette
édition je retrouve dans une trentaine
de minutes toujours pour une émission
spéciale
là aussi commémore le 75e anniversaire
de la victoire sur l'allemagne nazie
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
pour tenter de limiter l'impact de cette
crise économique liée aux colis de 19 un
plan de soutien à hauteur de 110
milliards d'euros a été déployée
resteront et société d'événementiel des
indépendants vont mettre la clé sous la
porte
quelles que soient les aides qui leur
seront accordés à gaza derrière si
l'économie ne repart pas si la confiance
ne repart pas elle va être terrible vous
savez aujourd'hui on perd près d'un
million d'euros par jour et on peut
considérer que non seulement avril mais
aussi le mois de mai